prügeleien im supermarkt pöbeleien in
öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln
ich sehe immer mehr solcher videos in
den sozialen medien und da liebe sogar
auseinandersetzungen auf der straße
deshalb frage ich konflikt expertin kati
nellenburg warum passiert das
gesamtgesellschaftliche anspannung
einfach dadurch dass wir alle von den
corona maßnahmen oder auch für eine
angst vor corona je nachdem was ein mehr
stress beeinflusst sind also das heißt
alle konflikte die es normalerweise auch
gibt im alltag sind erstmal mit einer
schicht stress quasi etwas noch mehr
belegt auch ich habe das gefühl dass
viele menschen gestresster sind
besonders in supermärkten und
öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln
ob das wirklich ein crooner liegt kann
man aber schwer feststellen sagt die
berliner polizeigewerkschaft und soziale
medien können unsere wahrnehmungen auch
verzerren die anzeigen wegen beleidigung
jedenfalls sind in berlin im vergleich
zum letzten jahr um zehn prozent
gestiegen sagt die polizei
die konflikte die ich erlebe drehen sich
zb um das tragen von masken maria
almeida eine in berlin lebende
brasilianerin wurde von einer frau ohne
maske im zug belästigt
ich habe sie zweimal höflich gebeten
vielleicht einfach woanders hinzugehen
und woanders hin zu sprechen
das hat sie nicht gemacht und war mir
gegenüber sehr aggressiv weil ich eine
maske getragen haben ich bin
aufgestanden und weg gegangen ich habe
mich sehr unwohl gefühlt und hatte ein
bisschen angst in meinem umfeld finden
manche dass die stimmung aggressiver
geworden ist andere aber nicht
ich frage mich ob leute die wegen ihres
jobs jeden tag mit vielen anderen
menschen zu tun haben stärker betroffen
sind betreffen imke zimmermann eine
kassiererin die bei ihrer täglichen
arbeit aggression erlebt
das könnte auch wirklich personen die
schon rein kamen und wirklich gedacht
haben eintragen können soll ich mich
auch in einem fall
und da haben wir nicht gesagt na dann
können sie leiden nicht einkaufen gehen
dann ist er richtig 80 geworden die an
der kasse am liebsten hätte sie auch für
ein oder zwei wochen von zu hause
gearbeitet erzählt imke wobei
durchzuatmen
[Musik]
die hälfte aller deutschen fühlt sich
durch corona gestresst heißt es in einer
umfrage
und dieser stress offenbart die gräben
in unserer gesellschaft
also es gab schon immer
bevölkerungsgruppen die gefährdete waren
angefeindet zu werden im öffentlichen
raum es ist grundlegend so dass sich
frauen immer verallgemeinernd gesagt
ungeschützter geführt haben im
öffentlichen raum als männer
es war immer so dass schwarze menschen
oder people of colour waren ungefähr zu
werden als weiße menschen im
öffentlichen raum
das hat mandy erlebt sie will anonym
bleiben
die leute sind wütend weil sie während
des lockouts daheim eingesperrt sind und
suchen jetzt einen schuldigen und sagen
china ist schuld wegen den chinesen
passiert das alles
und weil andere asiaten in ihren augen
auch die chinesen aussehen werden wir
alle dafür verantwortlich gemacht
mittlerweile will mandy auf der straße
verbergen dass die asiaten ist in zeiten
von corinna trifft aggression oft die
schwächsten
ich hoffe dass ich das mit der lockerung
der restriktionen ändert und dass solche
videos nicht mehr allzu lange in meiner
timeline auftauchen